the pope is beginning a historic trip to
canada where he's set to apologize for
the catholic church's treatment of
indigenous people pope francis was
welcomed yesterday by prime minister
justin trudeau and indigenous leaders
the pope is seeking to atone for the
church's role in the abuse of native
children at government-funded boarding
schools chris lipsey will be traveling
with the pope this week and is in the
canadian province of alberta chris good
morning
good morning pope francis is beginning
his seven-day trip here in edmonton the
capital of alberta today starting around
noon he's meeting with indigenous
leaders to address one of the most
shameful chapters in canadian history
he's expected to apologize for the
rampant neglect physical and sexual
abuse indigenous children face in
canada's residential christian schools
most of them run by the catholic church
from the late 1800s to the 1990s more
than 150 000 native children were taken
from their families to attend these
schools the goal to strip them of their
culture and language in an effort to
assimilate thousands are believed to
have never made it home back in april
the pope told indigenous leaders
visiting the vatican that he felt sorrow
and shame for the role some in the
church played in the abuse but this will
be the first apology on canadian soil
something indigenous leaders have been
calling for
pope francis will spend the rest of the
week conducting both public and private
meetings and for many this is a step
towards healing not to mention a very
important apology in the very country
where this cultural genocide took place
but for others it's far too little and
it's far too late for cbs morning's
chris livesay edmonton canada